fachleute sind optimistisch das
unbemannte flugzeug sie es schon sehr
bald passagiere von a nach b bringen
städte wie los angeles singapur und
dubai könnten in pilotprojekten schon
2020 mit kommerziellen passagieren
drohnen durchstarten aber auch in
deutschland laufen projekte in sachen e
mobility eine wichtige modellregion ist
ingolstadt ein elektrischer city airbus
soll hier bis zu vier personen durch die
luft transportieren krieg zum science
fiction gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
sie sind ja wohl der traum aller pendler
einfach einsteigen und das ziel schnell
und ohne stau umwege und verzögerungen
erreichen auch die nervige
parkplatzsuche hätte man sich so ganz
einfach gespart im besten fall sollten
flug taxi ist auch noch kostengünstig
und umweltfreundlich unterwegs sein
so könnten wir dann vor allem in
verkehrsreichen städten endlich aufatmen
denn die situation mit dem endlos
verstopften straßen wird nicht besser im
gegenteil schätzungen zufolge werden im
jahr 2030 gut 60 prozent der
weltbevölkerung in urbanen regionen
leben das heißt dass sich mehr als 500
millionen menschen jeden tag durch staus
auf den straßen quälen müssen und
deswegen sind sich viele fachleute
sicher dass der nahverkehr in der luft
die mobilität der zukunft ist ein
testprojekt dazu ist gerade in der
region ingolstadt angelaufen und ja hier
wird tatsächlich das ausprobiert was
anfang der 80er jahre der hollywood film
blade runner thematisiert hat fliegende
autos nämlich konkret geht es um den
sogenannten city bus und wie der name
schon verrät steckt der europäische
flugzeugbauer airbus dahinter der mini
airbus wird elektrisch betrieben und ist
mit vier doppel rotoren ausgestattet
somit kann er sowohl senkrecht starten
als auch landen und dabei vier
passagiere befördern und der
elektroantrieb macht den flug nicht nur
emissionsfrei sondern auch geräuscharm
und airbus steht damit nicht alleine da
auch boeing tüftelt schon lange an der
idee der lufttaxis die in zukunft
gewöhnliche busse bahnen und taxis auf
dem boden ergänzen könnten ein erster
testflug mit dem prototypen eines
elektro lufttaxis fand schon anfang des
jahres statt und zwar in den usa allein
bei airbus sind mehr
100 mitarbeiter in den bereichen
mobility dran auch das zeigt dass das
ganze ein wirklich großes thema ist
dennoch wird der begriff taxi zunächst
auf eine falsche fährte legen genau
genommen handelt es sich bei solchen
lufttaxis nicht um taxis die
individuelle routen möglich machen der
sind die abo soll stattdessen von fest
definierten punkten zu anderen punkten
fliegen und passagiere befördern ein
konkurrenzmodell also zum auto und zum
öffentlichen nahverkehr auf der straße
dabei ist die spitzengeschwindigkeit des
airbus flug taxis von 120
stundenkilometer mit dem eines autos
vergleichbar doch klar ist auch dass man
zumindest in der theorie
dort die schneller sein ziel mit einem
solchen fluggerät erreichen könnte die
reichweite formen sind die airbus
beträgt 50 kilometer womit kürzer flüge
innerhalb einer stadt durchaus zu
bewältigen sind
das bestätigt auch jörg koose ein
sprecher von airbus solche luftfahrzeuge
werden wahrscheinlich nicht von stadt zu
stadt fliegen die ersten praxis setzt
werden im sommer auf dem testgelände in
der nähe von ingolstadt staaten manche
fachleute gehen davon aus dass die luft
tax ist dann schon im jahr 2030 zwischen
dem flughafen münchen und dem
hauptbahnhof in ingolstadt pendeln
könnten dieser meinung ist
beispielsweise harry wagner professor
für automotive and mobility management
an der technischen hochschule ingolstadt
in einem weiteren schritt könnten
elektrifizierte flug taxis ohne pilot
schon 2035 auch in städtischen gebieten
unterwegs sein wagner zufolge könnte ein
serien fertiges flug taxi bis zu einer
halben million euro kosten gefördert
wird diese idee die den verkehr
tatsächlich revolutionieren könnte von
der politik denn die europäische union
hat genau diese initiative mit dem namen
der mobilität ins leben gerufen und
ingolstadt ist eine der modellregionen
weitere 15 europäische kommunen
beteiligen sich unter anderem hamburg
brüssel und toulouse und nicht nur die
politik und die luftfahrtindustrie ist
an solchen projekten interessiert
sondern auch die auto branche selbst
deutlich wird dass beispielsweise an den
start up volo copter aus bruchsal dass
ein projekt am frankfurter flughafen
plant und auch mit daimler
zusammenarbeitet von ihr könnten
passagiere mit einem wohl oper ins
stadtzentrum und zurück gebracht werden
und das voll elektrisch auf der webseite
von molo copter heißt es
18 leise rotoren einfachsten bedienung
per joystick und ein höchstmaß an
ausfallsicherheit durch redundante
auslegung der volo kocht da 2x macht aus
der vision fliegen für jedermann
realität kein verbrennungsmotor kann
kraft keine komplizierte mechanik
einfach einsteigen zufrieden und
entspannt ankommen
willkommen im neuen mobilitätskonzept
der gegenwart aus einer studie der
unternehmensberatung roland berger hat
das start-up damit genau den richtigen
riecher bewiesen
demnach entwickeln insgesamt 75
unternehmen auf der ganzen welt
passagier thronen und in anderen städten
wie los angeles dubai oder singapur
könnte es demnach schon 2020
pilotprojekte mit kommerziellen
passagier- und geben dabei ist der
transport von passagieren nur ein
einsatzgebiet unter vielen denn auch
waren könnten so von a nach b gebracht
werden und auch die
sicherheitsüberwachung von bahnstrecken
beispielsweise könnte durch solche
neuartigen fluggeräte erfolgen welche
fluggeräte sich dann letztlich
durchsetzen ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht zu sagen vorstellbar sind
laut fachleuten über ried konstruktion
multi und quadrocopter kipp pflügler
senkrechtstarter mit und ohne piloten
harry wagner schaut optimistisch in die
zukunft er rechnet damit dass es
unbemannten flugzeugs in der luft früher
geben wird als das völlig autonome
fahren auf der straße mit level 5
gemeint ist damit das völlig autonom
fahren bei dem das fahrzeug komplett
alle funktionen übernimmt
doch eine wichtige voraussetzung dabei
sei dass unfälle in der luft in jedem
fall verhindert werden dazu wagner es
darf nichts passieren sonst wirft uns
das um jahre zurück so oder so bevor
fluggeräte ohne piloten kommerziell in
die luft gehen müssen europäische
vorschriften her airbus selbst rechnet
damit erst mitte des kommenden
jahrzehnts und zwar frühestens wie
funktionieren selbstfahrende autos
anklicken anschauen und doktor watson
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran